Pour t'accomplir, tu dois t'oublier.
Pour te trouver, tu dois te perdre.
Nous vivons dans une société qui favorise Adam I,
et qui néglige souvent Adam II.
Le problème est que cela te transforme en animal perspicace,
qui traite la vie comme un jeu,
tu deviens une créature froide et calculatrice,
qui glisse dans une sorte de médiocrité
où tu réalises qu'il y a une différence entre ton moi désiré et ton moi réel.
Tu ne mérites pas le type d'éloge que tu veux,
tu espères que quelqu'un va te la donner.
Tu n'as pas de conviction profonde,
de prestance émotionnelle,
d'engagement pour les tâches
qui durent plus d'une vie entière à réaliser.
Je me suis rappelé d'une réponse commune grâce au processus
de création d'un Adam II solide,
de comment on construit une force de caractère.
A travers ce processus, les gens sont revenus
à leur propre passé,
parfois à un moment précieux de leur vie,
de leur enfance,
et souvent, leur esprit alla dans le passé
jusqu'à un moment de honte,
de péché, d'un acte d’égocentrisme,
d'un acte d'omission, de superficialité,
d'une colère, d'un apitoiement sur soi,
essayant d'amuser la galerie, d'un manque de courage.
Adam I est construit en s'appuyant sur nos forces.
Adam II est construit en vainquant nos faiblesses.
Vous cherchez en vous-même, vous trouvez le péché,
que vous avez commis tout au long de votre vie, votre « péché-mignon »
qui émerge au dessus des autres,
et battez-vous contre ce péché et luttez contre celui-ci,
au delà de cette lutte, de cette souffrance,
votre force de caractère se construit.
Nous ne sommes souvent pas éduqués pour reconnaître le péché en nous,
nous n'avons pas appris dans notre culture comment lutter contre lui,
comment l'affronter, et comment le combattre.
Nous vivons dans une culture avec une mentalité d'Adam I
où nous avons du mal avec celle d'Adam II.
Enfin, Reinhold Niebuhr résume cette confrontation,
la vie complète vécue avec Adam I et Adam II, ainsi :
« Rien de ce qu'il vaut la peine d'être fait ne peut être accompli en une vie ;
par conséquent nous devons avoir espoir.
Rien de ce qui est vrai ou beau ou bon
n'a un sens complet dans un contexte immédiat de l'Histoire ;
par conséquent, nous devons avoir la foi.
Rien de ce nous faisons, toutefois vertueux ne peut être accompli seul ;
par conséquent, nous devons avoir de l'amour.
Aucun acte vertueux n'est aussi vertueux
du point de vue de notre ami ou ennemi que de le nôtre.
Par conséquent nous devons avoir une forme définitive d'amour,
qui est le pardon. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)